de la boue du vent de la neige toutes
les conditions sont réunies pour vivre
ce dimanche une grande journée de cyclo
cross à lignières le berry s'apprête à
recevoir les meilleurs coureurs mondiaux
sur la carrière du pôle du cheval et de
l'âne et il y aura des surprises
on verra comment ça a fermé dimanche
matin si ça va dégeler s'il y aura de la
neige
on verra faut pas te faut pas être
rapide
ah non je pense que ouais si on vraiment
allé vite on va vite aller à la faute
donc faut vraiment être lucide one
deux ans après les championnats de
france lignières sera désormais le cadre
d'une manche de coupe du monde
plus de 200 participants évolueront dans
quatre catégories sous les yeux
d'environ 7000 spectateurs
le parcours doit donc être relevé il ya
très peu de dénivelé
donc du coup il ya très peu de
récupération parce que
voilà il faut tout le temps en
permanence on va dire pédaler et puis
après il ya des enchaînements avec des
virages très court et ça ça plutôt
tendance à gênés un petit peu les
coureurs donc c'est une donnée
importante rencontre à l'inter
les différentes équipes de france
répètent leurs gammes sur ce tracé
depuis plusieurs jours
et tout commence à être rodé
contrairement aux apparences on est
plutôt sur une approche un petit peu
technique à mon coffret en bois sur les
trajectoires et puis on peaufine ont
peaufiné les réglages les pression des
pneus tout ce qui est trajectoire pour
être au top dimanche et lâcher les
chevaux dimanche
tous les coureurs voudront se montrer
cette course aura l'alluré d'une
répétition générale avant les
championnats du monde
ils auront lieu les 30 et 31 janvier
prochain à auch 2 zolder en belgique